it's very important to repair bare spots
in the lawn before weeds have a chance
to invade the process is simple the
first thing you need to do is prepare
the soil get rid of existing vegetation
if there are any weeds there and the
deeper you can work the soil the easier
it's going to be for the grass roots to
penetrate and it'll help help the plants
withstand all kinds of stresses like
like drought and heat so you're going to
want to fill in with some kind of a soil
I've just chosen a top soil that I
picked up at the garden center and I've
also included some compost compost is a
good way to help improve the physical
properties of the soil can help retain
moisture and nutrients so if you've got
a compost pile at home that you want to
use that's a that's a good way to amend
the soil the seed I've chosen is
perennial ryegrass we're in full Sun and
it also has a characteristic of quick
germination which is something that
you're looking for when you're trying to
fill in a bare area so for a small area
like this I am just going to mix the
grass seed right with the soil and I'm
using a three-to-one ratio of the soil
mix to seed one two three and then one
more of the seed
you wanna firm the soil because when you
have good feed to soil contact it allows
the seed to extract moisture from the
soil and simply by firming the area like
this you can reduce the establishment
time by by up to a couple of weeks so
it's really important and then the final
step is to keep the area watered you
don't want it sopping wet just keep it
moist
you don't want the seed or the seedlings
to dry out once they've dried out
they're done so once you've got good
germination you can back off on the
water that that will encourage the roots
to go deeper